Speaker 1: This is my absolutely favorite story
from the weekend. Remember the whistle blower
who was going to blow the lid off about the Biden
crime families, fraud and all these things that
Joe Biden and Hunter Biden have done? James
Colmer was talking about it. We saw clips of
Chuck Grassley saying this is this is explosive.
We're going to bring in the whistleblower. It's
all going to happen. The whistle blower is now
missing. The whistle blower is now missing. And
I know what you're saying. They probably just
don't want anything to do with this. Right.
They are using ominous language to say we. We've
got to figure that out. The whistle blower has
gone missing. Hmm. That's really, really weird.
Newsweek has a report. Republican admits key,
quote, enforcement against Joe Biden. Now
missing now. The term whistle blower was a
stretch to begin with because whistle blowers
suggest they are blowing the whistle about
some kind of crime. So far, we've not seen any
evidence of that, either of Republicans who say,
oh, the evidence is coming. We're going to get
the evidence. Now, the term that's being used is
an informant, but even that is being put within
quotes because it's not even really clear that
they are that Representative James Colmer,
a Kentucky Republican, admitted Sunday that
Republicans, quote, lost track of a key witness
in an investigation about the Biden family's
involvement in an alleged bribery scheme. This is
just amazing. What we what we have is a memo which
includes redacted images of transactions involving
bank accounts purportedly belonging to members of
the cry of the Biden family, which they believe
are evidence of crimes. Nothing's actually been
proven. You have to understand. So we go to Maria
BARTIROMO program on Fox News yesterday, and Maria
BARTIROMO tries to do this big dramatic. Wait a
second. Are you telling me. And it's just all so
transparently pathetic. Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: Hold on a second,
Congressman. Did you just say.
Speaker 1: Did you just say on live television?
Speaker 2: Did you just say that the
whistleblower or the informant is now missing?
Speaker 3: Well, we we're hopeful that we can
find the appropriate. Remember, these informants
are kind of in the spy business. Is that did.
Speaker 1: You just say, Congressman? You know,
they came to me and they said, sir, the Biden
crime witnesses missing, big, strong guys,
tears in their eyes. I said, how could that be?
It was because of Obama who has been treated,
has treated me very, very unfairly because of
the cupboards were bare when I took over for
him. I was getting calls day and night saying,
Sir, how do you do it? How are you doing it?
And we're going to be redoing Mount Rushmore very
strongly because the informant proves everything
about the Biden crime family. Oh, we can't find
him. Okay. Well, I'm sure that that's something
that the Biden crime family orchestrated. Right.
It's the Hunter Biden body count or whatever it
is. The next thing is going to be the way that
this conversation has gone. If you look at it from
the beginning is so pathetic that it's actually
shocking. Maria BARTIROMO is even playing along
like even for her is it's it's a bit much because
the way the conversation has been was Colmer and
Grassley and others came forward and said, we have
a whistleblower who has all sorts of incredible
evidence against Joe Biden that crimes were
committed. Oh, okay. Have you seen the evidence?
Well, no, no, no. But I'm sure that he has it
and we're going to bring him in very soon. Oh,
okay. When is he coming in? Well, actually, he's
gone missing now. Oh, that's that's really kind of
strange. And Maria BARTIROMO, false for the
entire thing. Here she is wrapping it up on
Fox News. And it really seems as though she
will believe anything Republicans tell her.
Speaker 2: Just stunning. A stunning
breaking news story this morning that
some of these people now may be missing. Mr.
Chairman, we're certainly going to be covering
and reporting your findings. Thank you.
Speaker 1: Though. With which findings? The
findings that there is no more whistleblower
because the whistleblower is missing or the
findings that you are going to get only if and
when you find the whistleblower, if you get them
to come in, if they have any evidence, if any
of the evidence checks out, and if any of the
evidence that checks out actually points to any
crime, even a single crime, which they've been
looking into for years and still haven't found
a shred of evidence about. They love to say,
you know, the left always goes after Trump
for all of this supposed stuff, But now we've
got evidence and they don't want to talk about
it. First of all, I've covered the story from
the beginning. Secondly, there isn't actually any
evidence claiming that someone you can't find has
evidence, right? That is not the same as having
evidence. And the entire thing reminds me of when
Tucker, remember Tucker Carlson, He went on TV
when he still had a show on Fox News and he said,
we got a copy of the hard drive. We got a copy of
the Laptop from Hell, the Hunter Biden laptop from
hell. We got the copy on a USB drive and we sent
it to ourselves across the country and it got lost
in the mail. Really? You didn't make like a cloud
backup. You didn't keep a USB drive with you. You
didn't think to duplicate it. Now it just it's
been lost. We finally got Hunter's hard drive,
but it simply was lost in the mail. It's getting
harder to believe that these are serious people.
And of course, James Komar has been a serious
person for a very long time. So, listen, as I've
said before. I don't care about Hunter Biden in
terms of protecting him or politically motivated
reasons to pretend he did nothing wrong. Just
find me evidence of crimes and then I will say
prosecute Hunter Biden, but more importantly, find
me a link to Joe Biden before I'm going to think
that there's actually political relevance. They
have nothing. Do not allow yourself to be misled.
They have nothing as of right now. Okay, Real
quick. Two weeks from today, Monday, Memorial Day,
we are doing a one day membership blowout special
to officially start the 2024 campaign. The debates
are going to start. It's going to be insane.
Okay. So Monday, Memorial Day, that's the 29th,
I believe. Is that right? I don't even know what I
don't even know what year it is. Yes. Monday, May
29th. One day Membership special. Biggest discount
of the year. If you've been thinking of supporting
the work that we do. I would love for for you
to get on my newsletter mailing list. You go to
David Pacman dot com. You just type in your email
address. Very easy to do. And Monday, Memorial
Day in the morning, you'll get an email and it'll
be an email crying that will tell you how to take
advantage of this great membership discount.
I'll say more about it between now and then.